(pleurs)
- Ils étaient nombreux à ne pas
pouvoir retenir leurs larmes...
fils l'a déjà connu quand
il était petit, parce que c'est
le fils du collègue à mon mari.
- Des proches de l'adolescent
de 16 ans, des agnants
aussi, se sont rassemblés en sa
mémoire dans ce parc du quartier
Saint-Michel à Montréal.
- Je pense que c'est injuste
pour l il s'est fait
tuer. Je pense que c'est
injuste.
- Il n'y a pas de mots
assez forts...
- Avant le débutche,
des élus ont pris la parole,
comme le ministre du Patrimoine
Pablo Rodriguez...
- On veut de l'action!
-... qui a été la ciblea cibleae
de critiques de citoyens
qui réclament de meilleures
interventions du gouvernement
fédéral concernant l'accès
aux areu.
- Le gouvernement fédéral
cache son inaction derrière...
j'appelle ça une diarrhée
verbale!
- Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire?
Il faut que le gouvernement
fédéral prenne le leaddans ce d.
- Comment expliquer la mort
violente de trois adolescents
dans les derniers mois à
Montréal? Cette intervenante
émet plusieurs hypothèses.
MYRIAM BOUSKSOU, intervenante
jeun., Forum Jeunesse St-Michel
- On a la COVID qui n'a pas
aidé, d'accord? Le confinement.
Il y a l'enjeu de...
au niveau de la prévention.
L'accès facile aux armes
que nous, intervenants,
on n'arrive pas à comprendre.
Et le politique nous dit...
voilà, c'est... on se jette
les balles entre le fédéral,
le provincial. Mais...
c'est rop tard.
- Pour tenter de trouver un sens
au drame, cette adolescente
a lancé une pétition desti
à interpeller les élus.
- Elle a pour but justement
de... elle a pour but,
dans le fond, d'augmenter
la surveillance de la part
des patrouilleurs dans les zones
scolaires des milieux à risque,
ent pour protéger les
jeunes enfants. Ce qui me met
en colère, c'est qu'on dirait
pour justement stopper
violence-là.
- Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada,